hey I've got a voicemail today at two  one nine to david p which is a voicemail  tattling to me about something crazy  that sam cedar said take a listen to  this  hey david this is michael from boston  wanted to speak with you about sam  cedars comments the other day about  being in favor of the straight pride  parade oh yeah wanted to see if you were  also in favor of the straight pride  parade feel free to give me a call back  thing yeah oh wow i'm so shocked  how could sam cedar do this how could  sam cedar abandon everything that is  good and wholesome and say he supports a  straight Pride Parade  I can't believe Sam would do that and I  am going to really have to give him a  piece of my mind about this because he  is dividing the progressive movement by  support give me a break okay give me a  break we've got a great bonus show today  I hope that you will subscribe @ww join  pakman.com get the bonus show get a 40%  discount with the coupon code this is  20/20 why not